the old man in the dock
is one of america's most prolific
rapists and murderers
his stare unflinching as girls and young
women he attacked four decades ago
addressed him in court the horrors he
inflicted on them
undiminished by the passage of time
i still sleep with two phones and the
keys on the bed when my husband is away
one woman identified as peggy described
being home with her sister at just
15 years old when d'angelo struck
i was hit several times on the head
before being tied up gagged
and blindfolded we were both threatened
and i was raped multiple times
we were both left with numbness in our
hands for several months because our
wrists were bound so tight
it hurt to brush my hair because he had
hit me so many times on the head
joseph deangelo was in his seventies
when he was unmasked as a former police
officer
a husband father grandfather
finally identified after a dna match
two years ago he's pleaded guilty to
killing
13 women and raping nearly 50 more
in sacramento california in the 1970s
and 80s
victim after victim described his
torture and
torment my safety was shattered
as a masked man d'angelo
yielding a knife told me he would kill
me
if i didn't do what he demanded he raped
me
repeatedly moving me in and out of the
house after each time
he made himself comfortable in my home
and he stole my family's personal
belongings
as i lay helpless or sat tied
gagged blindfolded and naked
there are dozens more attacks too old to
be prosecuted
and he's outlived some of the women
whose lives he haunted
my mother told me that day when he was
caught she was going to look him into
the ice
and testify to what he had done
to her to my father and to our family
unfortunately that did not get she did
not get to see
that day in court she died the day
before mother's day in 2016.
some say d'angelo is feigning frailty to
win
sympathy under a plea deal he faces no
death penalty
but life in prison after inflicting a
life sentence
on so many young women and girls
sally lockwood sky news los angeles